hey guys welcome back to brand-new
bitter we're back I'm following a and
today I just wanted to show some quick
duels with the new mascot that came out
for all of the heroes in for honor this
is obviously part of the new event I
just want to show it off a little bit
just so that you guys can see what it
looks like and stuff let me know in the
comments below what your favorite mask
outfit is whether it be the Knights the
Blackman the samurai and with that let's
get into the duels for today and the
first match of the video is who would
have guessed it against a [ __ ] warnin
that's a little y'all season 7 has been
either way rep 70 plus I believe overall
rf8 warden so he pretty much knows what
he's doing with this character so I'm
gonna go easy see what he's thinking see
his moves and stuff gonna show off the
new execution how are the new effects
and stuff this guy's really loving this
mode just little stands the way yeah I
hate going here okay he's definitely
spacing himself out he's giving me he's
getting himself some space or respect
that go trade there see if I could try
to get a light parry off this no I'll
take the heavy bell it's basically what
I was going for these within the kill
range of a zone but I'm gonna chill out
of it hopefully just pop out a random
heavy see it works at the time just
throw a reign of heavies and it works
that's just actually a really sick
execution I like that I like that the
mass shows I'm not too big on the fact
that the person glows red but you know
still a good execution regardless my guy
to
let's see if we can do in round two
maybe I make this a three Oh game not
sure yet he hasn't done the valium
breakthrough yet I'm very surprised as
he dodged his forward and attempts to
maybe do that
Oh whilst my tracking a bit there ah as
I said it I didn't expect him it didn't
actually expect to deflect that only
because I thought I parried it which
sucks I parried it and I was gonna go
for a move but that didn't seem to work
ah [ __ ] that's gonna hurt me hard
no good stuff I was expecting for him to
either do the zone which I did guess but
I was also expecting him to just do just
you know just throw random light in
there just for the quick damage I was
not expecting the guard break I try to
predict the moves that the person does
depending on the situation whether I'd
be far apart or really close to him or
what my health bar is so and I end up
guessing wrong which sucks but it's only
tied 1-1 I mean it's still got tons of
time
maybe he'll do the valium breakthrough
to start this wannabe dashes forward if
he dodges for and I'm going me leaving
that situation i he caught me he guessed
that good on him o mystic that's where a
perfect heavy a heavy like combo would
go perfect for gladiator I feel like he
doesn't need it but it'd still be cool
if he had it and just end that with the
zone real quick how's that Kuwait
clean flawless game I believe it was
false I took a little bit of damage from
the chip damage I believe it was but
other than that was basically flawless
Mazzio go sir on God's it it works every
time I got me on the dodge I was in them
I was a middle of doing a buckler hit I
was gonna hit him with that sucker punch
but he got me shouldn't be dodged in
that close bud
I believe he's either one hit or really
close that's what that sucks
unlock roll it works good stuff I [ __ ]
up a bit I shouldn't have done that
I was I was close but then I was was not
expecting the valiant breakthrough I
still need to get better on that timing
I'm getting close
it's just sometimes people use it in
different situations uh like a lot of
wardens I see will use that as an opener
then some people just do it for no
apparent reason and it's really hard to
guess it sometimes so I'm getting I'm
getting close to getting that timing
down I almost have it I want to get out
of this door damn that's that sucks
she'd be pairing those but I'm [ __ ] up
I'm getting really close to pairing it
ah I should have been a deflects but
I'll take Perry anyway it's decent
damage nothing too crazy but it's still
damaged and he's backing up hard man I
don't know what his plan is but it's not
gonna work
I might get a Perry in right now that'd
be great
that's gonna be GG on that one if I do
take him in three - boo bit of a close
game a little bit of a close as well as
a close-up of the mask which is pretty
dice but I'm glad let's see what happens
in game 2 and the next match is gonna be
against the same dude once again but
he's actually on Ken saying now instead
of warden which is a bit of an
interesting change obviously Ken says
different play style immortan so maybe
he'll swap it maybe I get to I get to
learn his other set of moves or whatever
he never ever this guy has playing now
because he is a rep 13 Ken say but he's
erupting 8 warden so he has a little bit
more experience I believe on this
character this should have been a parry
but I was fishing for deflect
I couldn't light it I was expecting more
of the Swift strike but I'll take that I
definitely lost that run because I tried
to deflect the swish strike of all
things and I shouldn't have done that
anyway cuz it has hyper Armour
immediately after it with the next move
so that was really stupid to me I keep
forgetting about the hyper armor yeah I
just learned to probably just parry that
more and not try to deflect it trying
out for style points we'll see how this
flight goes oh okay a little quick
little quick lights I got the gummy in
the hyper armor see that's why I
probably shouldn't deflected it even if
I did if I managed to deflect it I
shouldn't have done that anyway because
then it would spend hyper armor there's
no point I got me on that as well so
strike came in perfect time I was
thinking of the guard break but I
probably should have stopped and just
smack them but it was the Swift strike
so if I went it worked anyway damn down
to oh maybe we could come back this
round
yeah see now I'm starting to get the
time we got the Swift strike even though
even though I've always known about the
timing I'm not starting to utilize that
more because now I can easily parry that
and get some zone it's a decent zone
damage we caught me on that that was a
good one they're gonna catch who s gonna
hurt me a lot not as much as I thought
it would be but you know it's I'm okay
with it
he's definitely then kill range now he
went to go for the feint and I was like
[ __ ] it might as well swing cuz I have a
feeling he's gonna do a move right after
it and it managed to work in my favor
because he didn't expect me to randomly
whip that in the middle of his zone
because no one ever swings the zone
three times then kinda say yeah I rise
feint it that's just how it works I'm
not gonna go for that move again I'm not
gonna go for the dashing light cuz he
seems too he's blocked it a couple times
and he's probably really close to
getting the timing down preparing it so
I'm not gonna bother with that because
that would just be free damage I don't
want to do that already so close to
losing this game
and I can just spam zone because I'm a
gladiator what else would I do
all right caught me on the lights okay
mana stamina that's not really good
right now but him guard breaking me is
really not helping him and I'll take
that fourth win and AH or I'll take the
win in not foreground tutitu big
comeback I should I'm gonna fight him
back here I don't want him yeah I don't
want to give them that opportunity there
if not really gonna do me and he'd do
him any good either
just as this area but might as well try
not to let any guard breaks hit me since
he isn't here a lot of walls that can be
lots of heavy damage to me he [ __ ] up
on the swift strike did a little bit too
early I believe I think it was to her
there was too late I couldn't tell what
it was but it was he I was obviously not
good enough because I hit him barely
caught him
and I went through his guard twice
interesting I don't know I never
understand why the weapons do that when
he clearly it looked like he clearly
guard broke that but then it went right
through maybe he was trying to swing at
the perfect time
I don't know me the way man good fight
was a big comeback and the final match
is gonna be against a new person this
time and it's going to be a peacekeeper
ref five PK didn't check the overall but
either way ref ipk probably knows a
little bit about the character probably
not everything but I would say roughly a
good amount that's wrong roughly ref I
would be you know there's not much to
this character the light spamming but
you know it still works you still do
things seems to be definitely enjoying
the light spam here oh oh okay
caught that one Hey look at the auto
phone I'll be rude with you
I didn't mean to parry that I was going
for his own and I parried so that was
not on reaction I'm not trying to make
myself look good
that was super lucky but I'll take it
though hey you can't beat you can't
complain about good things
Oh hit me with that D fly see I can't do
that with you cuz you're a [ __ ] prick
and this just seems to do she seems to
be doing zone cancel and a bleed like
bleed the bleed heavier whatever the
[ __ ] it's called you know she's done
that twice so I'm expecting her to do it
a third I'm kind of expecting her to do
a third time yep spectres do three times
but I was also suing her just let it rip
has been three times usually you don't
like to do it a lot man she loves spam
in that zone cancel i well maybe we'll
just get lucky if she zone spins me
again I'll try to actually parry it this
time a reaction
because even if I do end up not getting
the parents you actually lets it rip
this time the only thing that's where
they're gonna be cost me is an extra bit
of damage that bleed is a lot more
deadlier than the second part of her
ozone so I'm not really too stressed out
if I actually don't parry it from as I
can't keep my guard on that side which
is a huge issue because then if I were
to this would be a hell of an easier
fight man you are loving you love spam
in that zone don't you right through
that guard give me that second win one
more we're real close
or she went for that running guard break
you thought though don't [ __ ] you see
they're gonna spam she's you're gonna
spam the zone I'm here just start life
spamming oh I got me in the move
[ __ ] that's not good she's gonna um you
know if I can unlock rollout of that
thing I gotta stop doing that move
that's costing me a lot ah see I told
she was gonna let it rip at least once
just gonna get that confirmed damage and
she's [ __ ] straddling that tree but I
caught her good fight at the 3-1 victory
that was impressive I didn't actually
think I was gonna win against that PK
they're very lights being me especially
on Council and my guard it was just not
good but yeah guys it's going to be the
end of the bait a hope you guys didn't
mention to get three wins in that fight
when I got to Ken say the warden in the
piqué piqué probably gave me the most
trouble but I was impressive that I
accidentally accidentally parried that
bleed attack I've never done that before
but yeah hopefully guys did enjoy that
let me know if you guys think that the
masks up it's really cool I think it's
actually incredibly cool I prefer the
Knights one and then I like the samurai
one Vikings would be last but they're
all still really good as well we'd like
to be been doing dress subscribe before
you knew it I covered the informational
side of foreigner and some gladiator
gameplay as well and it's a feature hero
gameplay in the future with the marching
fire heroes release as well but my two
most recent videos will be on screen if
you guys do want to check that out but
that guys hope yesterday I think of
arson